the evidence that convicted Nicola
Sarkozy came from a wiretap placed by
investigators looking into the financing
of his 2007 election campaign for the
French presidency
he was found to have conspired to secure
a prestigious job in Monaco for a judge
in return for inside information on an
inquiry into whether he'd accepted
illegal campaign payments from L'Oreal
heiress Lillian Bettencourt
said this
this seems stupefying to me it's open to
criticism questionable in French law and
we will not give up on this fight it's a
just a struggle in the face of a
particularly unfair decision
the lawyers will now approach France's
highest court the court of cussation it
reviews procedural aspects of cases but
not the facts
this isn't the only legal battle that
Mark sarkozy's Fall From Grace he's
appealing a conviction for illegal
campaign financing of his failed 2012
re-election bid
and prosecutors say the 68 year old
should stand trial on allegations that
form a Libyan leader muama Gaddafi sent
him millions of Euros in cash to fund
his successful 2007 bid for the
presidency
the only other president convicted by a
French Court was sarkozy's predecessor
the late Jacques Shirak he was found
guilty of corruption but not sentenced
to jail sarkodie won't have to wear an
electronic bracelet yet that'll only
happen if his last chance of an appeal
to France's highest court is rejected
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Paris